c'est la journée nationale des patriotes
vous le savez pour le québec l'a fait de
la reine pour les autres provinces
canadiennes mais également la journée
des abeilles et ce pour l'échelle de la
planète je vous dirai à la baie qui
n'est pas le seul insecte menacé de
disparition mais qui est vraiment
devenue le symbole des dangers pour la
biodiversité
j'en perds le ce matin avec pierre
giovinazzo et professeur à la chaire de
leadership en enseignement en sciences
apicole au département de biologie de
l'université laval
mais si audio peinado bonjour bonjour à
quoi alors c'est quoi en 2017 que l'onu
a décidé de créer la journée mondiale
des abeilles en raison de la menace de
disparition
oui mais certaines journées de
célébration pour observer le rôle vital
que les abeilles ont dans notre
environnement dans notre société de pour
notre alimentation donc c'est vraiment
une journée où on prend conscience de
leur importance dans notre environnement
de célébration de sensibilisation aux
six ans j'imagine parce que les abeilles
sont en péril on le dit depuis quelques
années quelle est la situation
exactement en 2019 la situation est
assez complexe disons lorsqu'on regarde
les abeilles et les pollinisateurs
abeilles
on doit comprendre que on doit
comprendre qu'il y en a de plusieurs
espèces d'abeilles sur notre planète
donc c'est pollinisateurs surnombre de
nombreuses espèces mais il ya eu une
espèce en particulier qui est toujours
identifié comme l'abeille c'est
l'abeille domestique notre avec il nous
fait une donne du miel que les
apiculteurs gère donc c'est cette
abeille là qui est là qu on parle
souvent lorsqu'on parle des abeilles et
sa situation mais elle est assez
difficile parce qu'elle vit dans un
environnement qui est en changement
continuel avec les l'augmentation des
surfaces agricoles l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires
je peux vous dire une chance il ya des
apiculteurs pour s'occuper de nos
abeilles lorsque sinon il y aurait des
problèmes majeurs en afrique du sud
est ce qu'on réussit quand même à
maintenir un bon nombre d'abeilles pour
éviter des conséquences importantes pour
notre écosystème
oui l'industrie apicole problème
canadienne mondial ce lundi rick est
très très forte cd les agriculteurs ou
d'allemands sont revus pour d'autres un
organisme d'apple à tim mondiaux et
c'est quand même assez spectaculaire
comme organisation sargos plus d'une
centaine de pays à travers la planète
et ces gens là sont tous travaillent
tous à pour l'abeille et puis bon il est
nourrice par exemple si je prends proche
de celle où par exemple ici au québec
actuellement nos agriculteurs
travaillent très très fort pour nourrir
des abeilles et les fêtes développer
rapidement durant deux mois de vie pour
qu'elles soient en forme pour polliniser
les bleuets du lac saint jean et je peux
vous dire que ça s'en vient vite le
début de la présentation du bilan se
fait toujours à la fin du mois de mai a
cancun on sait comme stratégiques l'oif
nous avons des bleuets ça prend des
abeilles et puis d'autres produits
québécois comme les canneberges les
pommes donc il ya quand même beaucoup de
produits très proche de chez nous dont
les avait son sont des clés si l
important est encourageant ça donc des
apiculteurs qui font en sorte de
renverser en tout cas le tenter de
renverser la vapeur pour éviter la
disparition de cette espèce d'abeille
parce que monde sensé à bella est ce que
c'est viable
on peut compter non certainement pas
donc l'on par des apiculteurs qui
s'occupent de leurs abeilles vous savez
je sais que ça existe
cette relation abeilles apiculture et
produit les lits des petits fruits parce
que il ya de moins en moins d'abeilles
sauvages
donc lorsqu'on fait de l'organisation de
ce qu'on développe les milieux urbains
et lorsqu'on augmente les surfaces
cultivées et ont détruit l'environnement
naturel dans lequel vivent ces les
abeilles sauvages vivent dans ces
vieilles vivaient dans ces milieux là et
lorsqu'on fait de l'expansion de
l'activité humaine
bien malheureusement on détruit de
l'habitat naturel de nos abeilles
sauvages aussi oui et la commune genre
de situation vous pour qu'on aime
production agricole qui soit efficace
dans plusieurs domaines
ben là on depuis la vie sauvage donc on
se tombe dans les apiculteurs qui
doivent lever leurs abeilles domestiques
alors et puis ça marche
pour l'instant ça fonctionne mais metz
et nancy
est-ce qu'un rôle qu'on peut jouer
monsieur madame tout le monde à la
maison là parce que là c'est le grand
week-end où on pense à notre potager à
notre jardinage éventuellement leur
planter c'est peut-être même déjà fait
mais est ce qu'il ya des sortes de
fleurs ou de fruits qu'on pourrait faire
pour favoriser l'autre ça mais c'est sûr
que je vous disais ne paie pas votre
argent et laisser les gens allaient
pousser se serait refroidi bonne idée
mais disons que toutes les salles et la
relation qui existe entre les plantes à
faire et les abeilles ça date de dix
millions d'années l'eau donc c'est une
évolution avec les fleurs et les
abeilles qui fait depuis tout le temps
une flore ça existe pour une arrivée
noté ces cétacés ou celle que soi puis
c'est pour produire le fruit et puis de
fruits ça peut être un plus et comme
j'ai dit à dom ça peut être suggère par
exemple de canola dans l'ouest canadien
pour produire des graines de canola mais
on utilise des abeilles domestiques pour
s'assurer la pollinisation des grands
donc est ce que tout le monde peut le
faire mais évidemment cultiver des
plantes à fleurs le but de faire
attention des plantes à fleurs et jane
vous savez il ya eu des controverses
parce que déjà distribué dès les paquets
de graines ou au japon bien faire mais
dans ces graines non il y avait des
graines qui était garé de plantes qui
t'as même pas canadienne
attention mais dont pour s'assurer de
planter des fleurs sauvages avait nos
fleurs sauvages canadienne global agency
lyonnais gagnent qui sont très
mellifères
alors c'est sûr dont ça veut dire qu'ils
produisent beaucoup de miel il avait il
ya donc lyonnais les abeilles sont
attirés vers site la loi naturelle
on va surveiller ça bien sûr sera temps
d'aller faire du magasinage de fleurs et
de plantes
merci beaucoup d'avoir une bonne journée
les rebelles
au revoir